Hello.
Hello, Sven.
How are you?
It's Frank Defratis.
Yes, I'm alright.
I'm glad I was able to get the number and get you in there.
I know it's getting late there where you are now and you probably want to get home for the weekend.
Oh, it's no problem.
I work very late.
So I start early.
Uh not very early, so I work late.
I I work late too.
I I got the last show up last night around midnight, so uh it's good to do another one with you today, and I'm glad we finally have a chance to talk.
I visited your website many times.
I'm very impressed with the work that you're doing with holography, especially with uh full color.
Yes, uh well uh how did that come about?
Oh well I started very early with it, but only with two colors, so uh but now uh I have a good uh setup and uh we make uh about uh four hundred color holograms each year f with the students.
Mm-hmm.
Small size.
Uh the ones you have on your website, they look like they're probably eight by tens or larger.
Yeah, eight by ten.
Eight by ten all of them.
No, that's a maximum.
Well, I've tried uh larger one, but um the setup is too small for uh for uh very big holograms.
What are you using like a f a four by eight newport table there?
Uh it's a stone table, in fact.
Oh no kidding.
Isn't that something?
That's beautiful work too.
Now you you're using all gas lasers with that, I presume.
Yeah, I have an organ no not an orgon a helium cadmium laser.
I have a diet pump jug laser and a helium neon laser.
Now the course that you run there, what type of students take that course?
Uh well I I have several uh electric engineering and uh uh well d different uh uh well we have had also engineering uh physics and so that is the kind of uh students and I have also a special course for uh holographers or people uh uh especially interested in holography.
Yes I I would assume that the course runs as a um a separate course to the physics and electrical engineering course but also as a uh primary course for the students who would wish to take uh holography as their primary study yeah something like that.
Well um I mean most of the holograms are made with uh uh with uh engineering physics or uh uh uh uh uh s such type of uh students but uh I have uh a a small group that's s uh especially interested in in holography.
Yeah.
And so they make different kinds of holograms like rainbow holograms and and uh color and and ordinary uh holograms like uh transmission holograms and reflection holograms in one color.
Now would your students once they've completed this course and they've received their degree would they then go out into the workforce?
Uh the workforce?
Yes, would they then go to try and get jobs doing holography in your country?
Well in in our country our country is isn't very big.
Uh the number of pupils uh the uh the number of persons in Sweden is uh eight million so it's not very easy to to find a job in holography here.
Now how long have you been involved with holography and how did you get started?
Well I was interested uh in holography already in I started in sixty eight, sixty nine and uh well I I I was interested in stereoscopy and photography and so on so uh I tried to make uh in fact uh film in in three dimensions and such things so uh I I I was uh amazed by the pictures uh and the holographic pictures so I I tr I started very early.
Was it very difficult getting the uh university to set up a holography lab or were they very willing to do that?
Well uh uh well I I it wasn't it was not very s uh not very difficult to to get a lab like this in the beginning and then uh then we expanded a bit to then uh so now I have in fact uh two large tables and one small and uh uh we uh working in three separate rooms and we have a lab nearby so it it's uh very nice I I th I think that it would be good if I could have uh international students to use the lab more uh and uh I think it's uh it would be nice.
I try I have had some s some international students.
Would the lab be open for people to rent the studio to do work in it.
Uh I I uh I don't think it's uh yeah well it's possible to d to do that maybe yes.
Why don't you tell a little a little bit about the university itself.
This is Lund Lund University?
Yes uh Lund University we have a technical part and we have uh another we have two parts so one is uh just in in technical technical faculty.
Yeah.
And the plates you're using are are are they they're called ultima plates, right?
Yes, that's right.
Yeah.
And how how's the response of those plates?
The response?
Yeah.
As far as your exposure times working with them.
I mean uh in fact uh I think there was a reduction in the time of three to four compared to Russian plates.
I used the Russian Slavish plates before.
Mm-hmm.
What are the uh holograms that are on your website, the full color holograms?
They're used uh is that the ultima?
Some are uh Russians and some are ultimate, yes.
Yeah.
I um I've only seen one full color hologram and that was many years ago, and I have not uh had a chance to even see one in front of me.
I've seen them on websites, but I uh I was in Montreal uh many years ago.
I think it was a show called Images in Time and Space, and that was the only time I've ever seen in front of me a full color hologram.
Okay.
Well uh I I have f for the moment I have a setup for doing a twenty by twenty five centimeter hologram.
Uh and I uh I have already tested w one plate and so uh and now the the the French plates are very good and I hope uh I hope I will uh get a very clear plate.
I already had one, so I I I trying another uh object just now.
Uh with the uh the actual diagram and the setup that you have on your website, I see the uh multiple laser beams passing through the beam splitters and being combined.
Is there anything that you need to do to the beam intensity?
What's the ratio uh for the RGB for the red, green and blue?
What's what's the ratio to one another that folks would be interested in hearing about?
Well, it's dependent on if I use the dial laser or the uh or the helium neon.
I I mean I'm I've made some experiments with that.
And um uh but uh the the um balance is mi merely nearly thirty f three thirty three thirty three for the moment.
That is okay.
Oh that that's very clever.
So the dyes in the plates are optimized so that you use the same amount of power for about the same yeah, yeah.
I mean there is a difference uh between the red uh diode laser and helium neon laser.
Yeah, the wavelength difference.
Yeah.
I think it's six three uh six hundred thirty eight.
I see.
So you'd be closer to that with the Heaney than you would the diode.
But I mean the no no no, I mean the diode laser is uh six hundred thirty eight.
Oh I see.
Okay.
But I don't know w exactly where is the m optimum and in fact I mean to compensate sometimes for the coherence loss I have to uh I have to uh uh change the ratios.
I see.
Uh you can see maybe in some uh uh holograms there is a green blue background because the the coherence length doesn't uh uh I mean the the coherence doesn't reach the back in the isn't that interesting?
I'll have to go back on there and and and take a look at that.
That's interesting.
Well it's uh I mean but if I have a I I made uh this uh spring I made one with a dire laser when there was no mode hop in it and then I uh the the background was white.
Yes.
But when I make larger holograms uh I think uh uh it's more important that um that I have a good coherence length.
That is why I try to get the dye laser working.
Well let's say you're doing an eight by ten plate.
Um what's your exposure time running for an eight by ten plate on your system?
Is eight is eight by no eight by ten inches.
Uh well let's say thirty by forty centimeter or so.
I've uh had some plates uh that size but they only twenty by twenty five okay uh the exposure time uh well something like uh three minutes or so I I have a sp uh have you seen uh I have an uh uh paper on the I think you were in the a conference in uh weren't you in uh Austria?
No.
Okay.
Uh I can send you uh the expl uh the the paper on the setup.
Oh, okay.
Did you have some holograms in there?
In the conference.
Did you provide a paper in a few?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I showed the uh holograms and and uh presented the setup.
Oh okay.
Yeah I think I've been to the website of the the last conference but uh and I've I've seen maybe you can get directly that uh the digital version of yeah I think I may have it bookmarked somewhere.
I don't remember a downloadable document on it though.
If you want to send them to me I'd I'd be happy to receive that and look look through that.
And if you want to I can include it on the web page with this show so other folks can download it too.
Okay.
Yeah so send yeah send that to me and I'll put that up with the uh with the show when it goes up uh I probably about two weeks I guess we'll go up with this.
Mm-hmm.
So how many students do you have in your class typically there?
I mean we we make we we have eight students and they make uh eight holograms in four hours.
Wow yeah you it's I mean this is they I mean this is part of half the time they use for the the uh color holograms and and half the time they study already made holograms.
I see.
So they get their own holograms and so they can put up the toe.
Well that sounds like a great class.
I don't think uh we have anything like that here.
No no uh probably not I haven't uh no yeah.
I know I know some colleges that are just uh setting stuff up with laser pointers uh let alone the type of uh setup that you have although there's a couple of high schools actually uh that have some great labs.
Uh there's one in Florida, Jacksonville, uh Florida, which is Inglewood High School.
They have a great holography lab for kids, but of course we're not doing full color work, but uh it's a beautiful setup.
But you have a color lab uh or a holographic lab w for kids too.
Yeah, I I I bring students in to uh do holographic workshops here, sure.
Yeah.
It's not too busy in the summertime like it is in the uh the school season when kids are uh working on science fair projects and things like that.
But it's it's nothing as complex as uh doing color work.
I mean a lot of them are middle school students and high school students and we come in and uh do the setup and just do a simple you know either single beam or split beam hologram depending on their project.
In fact I'm for the moment I'm just sitting at the computer.
I was working on I'm w working with digital holography too.
Oh that's interesting.
Tell us a little about that.
For the moment I I've tried a very long time to get uh the image and it just appeared on the on the uh computer here.
So how now you'll take that uh you'll take that digital data and what will you do with that?
Uh well we we have a project we try to make a digital microscope in fact.
Uh we have uh a digital camera and uh we are uh starting face I mean with holography the you you get the information, the face information also.
And that that information is very important in you can uh measure uh differences in uh in uh refractive index and so on.
I see.
So you're not g you're not actually generating a hologram from that data yet.
And I well uh I I can well what what uh you know m about digital holography or have you I wouldn't say I'm an expert on it but I'm familiar with it.
Yeah yeah.
So uh in fact w we just um put a screen uh a virtual screen in the field and we we can change the position of this screen and see where the image is focused.
I see.
And so um and also you you get the the face information from the hologram.
I see, I see.
And this is important.
This is all part of your students projects or is this a personal project of your own?
Well we we uh are running in in a way a company uh we're starting a company on it.
Oh really?
What's what's the name what's going to be the name of the company?
The the name is uh f uh Phi uh I don't know Phi company.
P P H I.
Okay.
Face holographic imaging.
Great.
Yeah.
And what will the final product be that you'll be manufacturing and providing?
Yeah we we have a prototype of uh a digital uh microscope.
I see, I see.
For the moment.
So we we will we continue we have the first version of it.
And it ties into holography, the there's a hologram involved which is an optical element.
No, there is no optical element.
It's uh it's uh C C D.
I see.
Okay.
So uh so we we have uh just just we record the interference feed between uh a reference beam and uh object field.
I see, and then that's captured on the C C D.
Yeah.
And then we reconstruct it in uh in a digital form.
Wow, what's what's the resolution of that C C D um well yeah.
The the resolution is something like uh ten microns or but um you can uh uh y you can over sample and so you can get finer details.
I see, I see that's incredible.
Well you have a lot of stuff going on there.
Yeah.
So for the moment we we also I uh uh uh I have had a student working on on uh holography uh inline holography with uh a terawatt laser.
They make um uh uh you can get over tunes of the fundamental.
So we he has made some uh pictures with forty nanometer light.
Wow.
Coherent light generated in uh in the laser.
You're saying this is a terawatt laser?
Yeah, that's that's because the um the uh pulses are very short, some hundred fef femty seconds.
Yeah, wow, that's absolutely incredible.
And what what would be a technical application for that?
Well for the moment we are just studying the principles and see what what is possible.
What's possible to do, yeah.
Yeah.
Worry about the applications later on, just get the results right first.
Yeah, we Yeah.
Yeah, well I we hope uh I mean uh you you go into uh interesting uh wavelength regions, so uh we hope in the future.
Well, Sven, it's is there anything you'd like to add to the interview before we close it out?
What would you like to say if you had a chance to say there's gonna be a lot of people listening to you?
Okay, I I I would like uh a lot of people to come here and do some uh color holograms.
Okay, and how would they go about doing that?
I don't I don't know for the moment.
I will find out.
I guess the first step would be for them to contact you, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, and I we'll have a l a link to your uh website on the whole talk page.
And if you send that document to me I'll also include that document as a download.
Yeah, okay.
And if anybody would like to do color holography now, would they have to actually attend the university in order to do color holography?
Yeah, I w I will find out w uh a way to uh I think i if if I get a lot of people interested in it w maybe we can uh arrange an international course.
That would be very nice.
Once again I Okay, well I'm glad we finally got a chance to speak to one another.
Yes.
And it was very nice talking with you.
It's very nice talking with you.
It's very beautiful work that you're doing.
I wish uh I wish I could have more experience with color holography or even just see one.
Because it's been so many years I I'd love to see one in front of me 'cause I imagine they must be breathtaking.
Oh yeah.
And uh the the color uh I mean the plates that Iv makes are very clear.
And that uh that's very I mean you you think the object is just behind in full color.
Which which was the whole point of holography really.
I mean we see a monochrome image uh you sort you you certainly do get that sense and of course of course we have uh pseudo color as well which if if done properly can give you uh a very much a sense of uh color within the image but I imagine true color holography must be m mind boggling.
I remember seeing one I think it was a Japanese hologram that I saw in uh Montreal when I was there and it just um I just could not believe it.
Yeah I I I have uh a nice setup to to do pseudo colour holograms too.
Mm.
Mhm.
But I think there there is one hologram or so which is pseudo color in the on the website.
Yeah.
Do you sell any of the holograms?
Uh no, uh that uh I ha I haven't s I I haven't uh touched up.
If someone went to your website and they wanted to buy one of those color holograms, would you sell it to them?
Well it's possible maybe, yes.
Yeah, if the price was right, I guess, right?
Yeah.
Well I uh I mean most of the holograms you'd I don't have more than some few.
Yeah, just one or two, I guess.
Yeah.
Same with me.
So so uh we also have had some some uh exhibitions.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, and you have a group here that uh is interested in holography and sometimes we we uh decide to make an exhibitions and so that's uh yeah if you sell the holograms you wouldn't be able to do the exhibitions.
No, okay.
Okay.
Well I want to thank you, Sven.
It's been very nice talking with you.
And I want to wish you uh a nice weekend.
I guess your weekend's getting started.
Mine is still have some time before I start mine.
It's only one in the afternoon here, but it was very nice talking with you and uh look forward to having your show up and I'm sure the listeners are going to enjoy it as well.
Okay.
Yeah.
Very nice to to speak with you.
Very nice.
All right, thank you very much.
Thank you very much too.
Okay.
Bye bye.